my name is ambreen and i'm the founder
of simply matai
a little mentai shop here in chicago
matai is actually
a traditional suite in india like any
type of happy event that happens
you get matai you graduated from
kindergarten great metallica celebrated
but then in america we just don't really
have those many options
my kids they don't like mitai indian
mithai
no and all my cousins everyone's kids
they don't like the mithai our
generation is moving away from
a lot of the standard mitai and
i just wanted something that's like a
beautiful box that i'm proud to like
give to my friends and family when we're
celebrating occasion
the one you get it here is not that
fresh or not that
made properly like that so
in fact i then i told her let's do the
infusion
american and indian so our signature
item is like these little box
chocolates and the bon bons are filled
with the traditional indians we call
barfi
we created the recipe together and then
i made the box of chocolate so she
brought the east and i bought the west
i grew up in india i was born and raised
there
but then i went to saudi arabia because
of my husband got the job there so
we went there and we stayed there for 14
years
so she went to culinary school in india
um and
growing up in saudi arabia my mom always
made
cakes like it was always a cake for all
of our birthdays and she would like do
this elaborate thing and um it's funny
there's like pictures of it now is like
growing up but that's like one of my
main memories is always like my mom
making a cake and she'd always like
write on it and i was always amazed by
that
i used to create you know whatever they
tell me they wanted some car cartoon or
whatever they wanted
i used to create them and they used to
be very excited growing up
my father when we moved to america he
was working really really hard he was an
architect back home but when he moved to
america he wasn't a licensed architect
so he was really making like thirty
thousand dollars a year
bare minimum we were starting
with four kids i have four kids two
daughters and two sons so
we were struggling and my only my
husband was working
so we have to meet the ends
it was very hard for us to do anything
there was a time when his company
decided that they were paying him too
much and they decided to lay him off he
felt heartbroken that he was just like i
can't believe this what am i going to do
now
but then once he finally was laid off
and kind of forced into this position
he ended up like flying because he was
like okay let me do this let me do that
and he explored with so many of his
entrepreneurial desires
and he ended up being so much more
successful and so happy
but then six months later he was
diagnosed with cancer and passed away
this all happened during my senior year
of college and when i graduated i was
working finance
and i just kind of like looked around
and i was like this isn't what i want at
all i'm like i don't want to spend
like you know 13 years down the road and
be in the same position my father was
and
pass away or you know who knows what
tomorrow holds um
so that was my main thing as to like why
i decided culinary school and why i
decided that i just wanted to pursue
something i actually enjoyed versus
numbers
do you think that now you and your
family have reached the american dream
not yet sky is the limit
so i don't know we want to
do it more because i want to encourage
my kids to do more and more
i'm so grateful for all of the
opportunities that i've been given like
being able to go to college and
succeed in my corporate life as much as
i have but then also have the ability to
start this business and be able to just
have zero limitations literally the sky
is the limit to be able to do whatever i
want with it and
to expand as much as i want and just
succeed if i
choose to continue to do so or tomorrow
i decide not to i can do that too right
like
it's just a beautiful thing to be able
to do that so to me now the american
dream is just living
just living a fulfilling life without
any restrictions